when you first load up the game
in cyberpunk 2077 you'll be greeted by a
character creation screen
but before rushing through the section
you should know that your choices will
carry some significance into the main
story
and one of these decisions is around the
life path of your character
so which one should you choose
even a small cosmetic detail could have
some impact on the way that the story
plays out
and when it comes to choosing your life
path this is no different
it isn't just to give your character a
small backstory and set the mood
your life path will serve as the
guideline for defining your personal
story
who you know who knows you and also the
choices you can make in quests
each path has a different starting quest
and location
it will also determine how others will
react to you your dialogue choices
and even how some of your relationships
will play out
for example a nomad will be much better
at communicating and getting assistance
from other nomads and inhabitants of the
badlands
a street kid knows all the street level
drugs dealers
and fixes of night city and a corporate
is more savvy when dealing with mega
corporations and their agents
your road to main quests beginning
alliances and essentially the way you
will complete the story
is unique to each life path
with all the excitement around the
action and bright lights of night city
it's easy to forget about the enormous
desert that surrounds the city
and the people who live there referred
to as nomads
these outsiders to the big cities came
together during the collapse in the 90s
many people lost their jobs and were
forced from their homes
a large number of families left the
cities and started banding together
to create convoys that would travel from
place to place
salvaging attacking fuel depots and
raiding corporate facilities for weapons
and vehicles
members take on different roles like
doctors teachers
and farmers in order to ensure the
continuation from generation to
generation
these tribes or clans are essentially a
village
on wheels the vast desert around night
city is a dangerous place
ravaged by wars pollution and global
warming
the nomads also need to watch out for
any mega court mercenaries
that manage to cross their path as
corporations tend to not be a big fan of
this stuff being stolen
regardless of what they do to survive
nomads are often seen maintaining old
world values
they place importance on community and
maintain a more traditional society
where all people are equal and have the
same opportunities
work ethic and family are important to
them
naturally this means that the nomads are
not particularly fond of corporations
and gangs
and will go out of their way to defy any
structure that has been put in place by
them
they place much higher value towards
integrity and freedom
however in cyberpunk 2077 choosing the
nomad life path will have you starting
out on your own
something has happened to your family
forcing you to leave the badlands
and enter the completely unfamiliar
territory of night city
born and raised in night city street
kids are accustomed to the lawless
and unforgiving nature of the large city
they have learned to survive in a
hostile environment
where might makes right
after the economic collapse in america
street children make up the majority of
youth
due to a combination of lack of public
schooling system
and increased workloads results in a
lack of supervision
by the age of six most strict kids are
left unsupervised for up to six hours
a day by the age of 12 this figure
almost triples
to 16 hours a day almost 90
of street kids are involved in some type
of youth gang
which often have affiliations to larger
more aggressive street gangs
by the time they have reached
adolescence if they have been lucky
enough to survive this long
they are often inducted into the parent
gang that they have worked alongside in
their youth
street kids know the city like the back
of their hand those who were able to
survive this far
have done so through their connections
and street smarts
knowing the local slang drug dealers and
fixers
is all a part of life learning to
survive on the streets
and depending on certain people as if
they're a family
positions of authority like the police
or corporate security
are avoided at all costs without the
money to protect themselves
street kids are often abused by the
police and other groups with power
so to keep surviving it's best to stay
out of this site
choosing the street kid life path will
have you armed with intuitive knowledge
of the streets
relationships with smaller gangs and
aggressive fixes
will be far less hostile drug dealings
the black market and the social
hierarchy of night city
will be of comfortable familiarity on
your path
the street kit is the ultimate insider
of the goings-on in the underbelly of
night city
nicknamed corporates they are the
managers employees
and agents who work for mega
corporations
[Music]
although their life may seem
particularly comfortable in comparison
to the average person
it is certainly no less dangerous
in the hugely competitive corporate
world corporates will go out of their
way to sabotage their rivals
or even colleagues in order to increase
their chances of climbing through the
ranks
power struggles dirty tricks and
backstabbing
are all a part of the lifestyle
corporates are generally cold
calculating and relentless
arasaka is a worldwide maker corporation
dealing in corporate security
banking and manufacturing it is one of
the most influential maker corporations
in the world and it's here that you can
find some of the largest levels
of in-house fighting around corporates
who are willing to bend the rules
and exploit secrets and information are
the ones who are quickly climbing the
corporate ladder
know the most powerful and influential
people in the city
they are able to read between the lines
and remain completely calm in front of
even the most intimidating people
their knowledge and power leads to doors
being opened that would otherwise be
unattainable for the average person
choosing the corporate life path will
have you placed in the high pressured
position of an arasaka agent
you will be located in arasaka tower
where you will be expected to navigate
the eternal affairs within the
corporation
as well as seize opportunities by
spending negotiations
and contracts in your favor but what
would happen if arasaka
night city's most powerful organization
suddenly turns
on you
so which life path to choose of course
there is no right or wrong answer here
but i probably suggest taking the path
that sounds most like how you would like
to play the game
on the first run through you'll have a
more immersive experience
so choosing the role that would more
likely follow your way of thinking and
the decisions you make
will only support this for example i
think i'll be starting out with nomad
of course i want to experience all the
game has to offer but on the first run i
want to be able to take
everything in at the right pace the game
is centered around night city
so by starting in the badlands i feel
like it would be a nice build up as the
nomad makes his way to the big city
after all the nomad is completely
unfamiliar with night city
and would be experiencing it for the
first time like myself
but at the end of the day it really
doesn't matter that much you can always
start over with one of the other life
paths
or you could completely ignore the
stereotype of the role you pick
and play it like you want like maybe you
could try playing a corporate
as a kind friendly person to everyone
around you i'm sure that will work out
fine
anyway i hope this video has helped
clear up some of the differences between
the life paths
let me know in the comments which one
you think you'll be starting with
otherwise thank you very much for
watching
and i'll catch you in the next one
cheers
[Music]
you